bill is in Rochester New York I bill
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so I'm a doc I'm 30 years
old I've got quite a lot of debt I'm
about 375,000 and debt I my household
incomes about 290 with my wife and I and
currently I also work or sort of consult
for nonprofit I've been in the public
service loan forgiveness program for
five years so I have about until about
twenty twenty-five which at that point
it'll be close to 500 or so my my loan
so I'm just wondering if you had some
advice for whether I should just keep
going on this path or try to pay it off
as fast as possible right now when I did
my calculations out with my income over
the next you know up to 2025 it looks
like I'd probably pay around 200 or so
in monthly payments I just aggressively
paid it off
which obviously wouldn't cover it I just
wanted to get your thoughts on that okay
let's start with this understanding the
average household income in America is
fifty eight thousand dollars a year you
make three hundred thousand dollars a
year right yeah okay
so why could you not pay a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year and be
debt-free in two years I don't know if
it would be you probably take me about
three years I suppose stop stop stop
stop
three hundred thousand - a hundred and
fifty thousand equals a hundred and
fifty thousand right but after tax rate
so I understand I understand taxes so
you're living on 75 or 80 thousand
dollars after taxes when when
pay your student loans off bill
fast as you can like two years two years
do it right now
what is your house worth oh we rent I
don't know how to run a house how much
is your rent mm what is your car payment
uh six hundred good god dude you make a
lot of money and you are really really
broke you have got to turn this around
so what I would do if I woke up in your
shoes is I would put my family on beans
and rice you're not a doctor
you're a broke doctor you make a pile of
money and you have none agreed you need
a chance yeah you make a pile of money
and you have none none you're broke
you're trying to figure out a way for
the government to bail out a guy that
makes 300k roll up your sleeves get on
beans and rice and do this two years man
change your life you can do it
don't wait on them to figure out some
way to fix your life you're gonna be
your life's gonna suck if the government
fixes it